The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: My intention
tonight is primarily
to provide you with some
suggestions, framings
that will help in your
viewing of these two films.
And we'll also,
at the same time,
reinforce and extend
some of the things
I was saying this afternoon
about Hitchcock's work
more generally.
And about the recurring
preoccupations,
themes, obsessions,
strategies that
are characteristic of his work.
And I want to begin by
adding one note to what I
was saying this afternoon.
You remember I began this
afternoon by talking about
the relationship between
Hitchcock and what I call
the "Genius of the System"--
borrowing on that famous
passage from Andre Bazin,
who said Hollywood is very
interesting, and there
are interesting directors,
but why don't we talk about
the genius of the system--
the way the system itself
encourages or enables complex
forms of narrative.
And we've already talked
several times earlier
in the course about this topic.
But there's another
way in which one
can think about this issue
with regard to Hitchcock.
And I think it's
helpful in clarifying,
so I want to mention it again.
One way to think
about Hitchcock is
to think of the Hitchcock film
as a kind of genre unto itself.
Right?
The Hitchcock.
Just like the Western,
or the screwball comedy.
Broadly, Hitchcock belongs
to the broad category
of what might be-- well, of two
categories-- the horror film--
although, he's a strange
director of horror.
He certainly is
incredibly influential.
In fact, when he made Psycho,
he publicly announced,
"This is my first horror film."
Even though there are
elements of horror earlier.
And it made something
of a publicity splash
when he said that.
So one way to
understand Hitchcock
is to think of him
as participating
in at least two categories
of genre or subgenre
that are more and more
widespread than Hitchcock's
work itself.
And we might call that the
horror film and the mystery
film.
And even that's a bit of
an oversimplification,
because within the
category of mystery,
you can have different
sort of subcategories.
One of which is the sort of
romantic adventure of the sort
that North by Northwest.
The chase film
starring Cary Grant
that Hitchcock made that
ends with characters
climbing across the
face of Mount Rushmore.
So that's one sort of
action-adventure version
of a mystery story
that Hitchcock makes.
Another version-- other versions
are examples of the films
that we're seeing tonight.
But my point is that although
one could fit Hitchcock's film
into some sort of larger
category-- of mystery
or mystery and adventure,
something of that kind--
it's also the case that once
you begin to look closely
at Hitchcock's
films, you can see
that there's such a profound,
almost obsessional coherence
in them.
They keep returning again and
again to those dominant themes
I talked about this afternoon.
That one can see that
they, in some sense,
constitute a kind of
category of their own.
If we think of-- so if
we think of the Hitchcock
as a kind of genre, even
within that category
we can discover
immense variation.
So that Hitchcock's
example itself becomes
a kind of crystallized,
or distilled example
of the principle I've been
talking about all semester
concerning the way in which
a system like the Hollywood
system could engender
variation, even as it is also
committed to giving its audience
something that seems familiar,
that they recognize, that
they're willing to attend
to week after week after week.
I think the primary point is
this-- in a system in which you
have any habitual, a regular, a
daily, or a weekly relationship
to the material, there have
to be elements of familiarity,
of repetition.
Of a return to shared
subjects and themes.
Or you wouldn't do it.
You would find it
intolerable every time
you made what was a routine or
habitual connection to a text,
if what it gave you was a
completely new experience which
forced you in some sense
to begin at the beginning
to figure everything
out for your--
you would find that you would
resist such an experience.
It's one thing to go to a
great overwhelming theatrical
experience once or twice a
year, or once or twice a month.
It's quite another thing to try
to watch King Lear every day,
or even every week.
So part of the
difference has to do
with the need to what it means
to have a habitual, rather
than an occasional,
connection to the artwork.
And one of the
fundamental-- well,
maybe the most important thing
about the Hollywood studio
film, and later the
most important thing
about American television
narrative forms,
is the is the intimate,
regular, routinized connection
that the viewer has
with the material.
And in the case of
Hitchcock, what we can say
is, really from
the very beginning
of his work to the end,
there are these fundamental,
emotional, and strategic,
or technical coherences,
resemblances, that made
virtually every Hitchcock
film a kind of commentary
on an earlier one.
And the two films you
are seeing tonight
are a particularly
rich example of this.
So I hope you'll think hard
about the way in which they
are both profoundly
different from each other,
and also at the same time,
strangely, mysteriously,
profoundly similar.
How they circle back on the
same kinds of obsessions
and the same kinds of problems.
And part of our pleasure
in looking at the two films
is the simultaneous
recognition of the difference
and similarity.
Well, that is an example in
small compass of the larger
principle of popular aesthetics
that I was saying needs
to apply to the way in which
we understand the audience's
relation to the
classic Hollywood film.
So as you're watching these two
films and thinking about them,
think both about
resemblances and differences.
And you'll get some sense of
how much remarkable variation is
possible within what remains
certain familiar conventions,
expectations-- not only about
the content of the text.
But also about the way
the text is organized,
about its formal features.
So what I'd like
to do then is say
a couple of introductory things
about each of the films you're
going to see.
And if I'm able to
keep the time right,
maybe we'll pause for one clip.
Maybe we won't,
depending on how concise
I'm able to be in my arguments.
You'll notice that Shadow
of a Doubt and Rear Window
are 11 years apart.
And I think that's
significant because one
of the most interesting
ways to think
about comparing the
two films is to think
about the way in which
Rear Window seizes on many
of the preoccupations
and themes that
are at the center of
Shadow of a Doubt.
But deals with them in
ways that one might say
are even more
disturbing and profound,
that press more deeply into the
implications that are mobilized
in the earlier film.
And maybe that
sounds too general
and abstract and mysterious.
Let me be specific
about what I mean.
One example is-- one of the most
interesting aspects of Shadow
of a Doubt, if you look down
to my next to the last item,
is what I call the subplot.
And the subplot in
Shadow of a Doubt
involves essentially a kind
of subsidiary story about two
very ineffectual characters.
In this subplot, the
husband of the family
has a kind of-- his
main preoccupation
when he's not working
at his bank-- is
he has an ongoing conversation
and sort of reading group
with his friend,
played by Hume Cronyn.
Also as a diminutive man,
also a man who seems to
lack masculine force.
He's short, he's not aggressive.
And they spend their time
reading murder mysteries.
And they spend their time trying
to devise the perfect murder.
So part of what's
funny about this,
but also macabre
in its own way, is
that while these
two sort of capon
like older men-- who stand for
a kind of impotent maturity,
a kind of useless,
unattractive maturity--
they spend their time
and their diversion
is to try to invent or
imagine murders and mayhem.
When in fact a real
murderer is living
at the heart of the family.
And Young Charlie herself
is actually in danger,
even though her father and and
no one around her in the world
understands that
that's the case.
Although the viewer comes to
understand it fairly early.
And even Young Charlie
comes to a recognition of it
before the film is over.
So in this subplot,
what's going on
is we have two
sort of characters
playing at the
diversion of murder,
and finding stories about
murder a kind of escape.
And in fact, one
of them is actually
trying to devise the way to kill
someone and get away with it.
And what we're
supposed to feel is
that this subplot is a reminder
to us about a number of things.
But most disturbingly
and subversively,
it should be a reminder
to the audience
of what the audience is
doing sitting and watching
Hitchcock's film.
Because the equivalent of
the audience in the movie
is-- one equivalent of
are these two sort
of foolish people
who, immersed in, and in
some degree surrounded
by evil and authentic
danger are living out
their silly diversions by
reading silly magazines
about murder stories.
So it's a variation on
Hitchcock's obsession,
or deep, deep recurring interest
in the space of entertainment.
And what it means to want
to go to entertainments.
And there's a certain sense in
which every single Hitchcock
film enables or is grounded
upon this experience of sitting
in the dark-- actually
what sort of equivalent
to what the Jimmy
Stewart character does
in Rear Window-- sitting in
the dark, anonymous peeping
watching the lives
of other people.
And the idea is not only
that you're anonymous,
but in some sense
there's something sort
of illicit about it.
As if in the
process of doing it,
you're indulging
what are base desires
or at least not totally
respectable impulses.
But you're doing it in a
space of comparative safety
and a place of anonymity.
So the subplot in Shadow of
a Doubt, in a certain sense,
raises self conscious
questions about the nature
of the entertainment
that we ourselves
are watching as
audiences for the film.
All right?
And it's clearly a major
dimension of Shadow of a Doubt.
It's one of the things that make
Shadow of a Doubt a rich movie.
There's a kind of cunning,
cynical complexity in it
that careless viewers, or
very superficial viewers
won't pick up on.
And it's really possible,
I could really imagine,
that they were viewers
who came away from Shadow
of a Doubt fully satisfied.
Thinking, oh yes,
evil has been purged.
What a nice mystery story!
Never fully picking up on
the dramatized elements
of the text, which
put in question
the ease with which we embrace
these forms of entertainment,
the ease with which we
accept murder and mayhem
as a form of diversion.
And some of the implications
of that for human nature
and for our ideas of
entertainment itself.
So that moment when in
Strangers on the Train
when the merry-go-round
goes mad and becomes
an instrument of
terror and murder
is another example of
Hitchcock's interest
in the complexity and
problematic nature
of our connection to what
we call entertainment.
And one of the
things you can see
when you shift to
Rear Window which
you can see how these
preoccupations have
been distilled and clarified.
Because the entire field
becomes a meditation
on the nature of our
voyeuristic impulses.
The entire film becomes a
story about seeing and not
being seen, about following--
about shadowing people,
about hidden impulses
or potential doubles
of our own respectable nature.
And the way in
which Rear Window is
self-reflexive or self-conscious
is much more systematic
and much more deeply
embedded in the experience
of watching the film
than was the case
with Shadow of a Doubt.
The same theme, the
same self-consciousness,
the same awareness of
the problematic nature
of entertainment,
but now much more
systematically and
fully integrated
into the formal and
thematic nature of the text.
So I love Shadow of a Doubt.
In many ways it's one of
my favorite Hitchcocks.
But it's early
Hitchcock, and you
can feel the much greater
rigor with Hitchcock
has begun to seize
on the implications
of his own problematic
relation to his material.
And his audience's compromised,
complicit relationship
to the material that Hitchcock
mobilizes in his film.
So Rear Window was more
systematic in some sense,
more coherently conscious of
this element of its meaning.
It's almost as if
by the time we get
to the mature films of the
'50s and beyond-- the period
between, let's say, 1951 in the
early '60s, when Hitchcock did
all of his most powerful work--
it's almost as if we can say
that the films of this era have
a kind of double significance.
That all of these
films-- all the films
after Shadow of a Doubt are
partly about filmmaking.
They're partly
self-conscious attempts
to be meditations on
the nature of movies.
And it's almost as if there's
a kind of separate story,
a separate plot.
There's the traditional
kind of mystery story
that, is characteristic
of many films.
But then there's this meta
story, this separate story.
It's the story of the filming.
The story of the
making of the film.
The story or the
drama of watching--
the drama of the watching,
we might call it.
The literary version
of this would
be the drama of the telling.
Right?
There are literary--
if you think
of a novel like-- a novella
like Conrad's Heart of Darkness.
I think I've mentioned
this before in the class
because it's such
a clear example.
But the story of Heart of
Darkness is really two stories.
It's the story of the narrator's
trip up the Congo River
when he was a young man.
But it's even more of the
story of his struggles
to tell the story
20 years later.
And when you read Heart
of Darkness, naive readers
hate it, can't figure out
why it's taking so long.
And why it's taking the narrator
so long to get to the point.
But of course, the
story is not primarily
even about the adventure
he's trying to talk about.
It's about the struggle
to tell the adventure.
So that there's a kind of
double plot in that novella
as there is in a lot of
great modernist fiction.
As there is in
another way in a lot
of great modernist paintings,
where you are aware
not only of the subject of the
painting, but of the materials
that go into the
making of the painting.
I'm thinking of the
great impressionist and
post-impressionist
painters, right?
Or of the painters
who would paint--
like Monet who would paint
50 versions of a haystack
in different lights.
Or 32 versions of Rouen
Cathedral in different lights
at different times of the day.
Why?
Well, one of the
reasons is, he's
trying to say that
reality is not stable.
That Rouen Cathedral
changes depending
upon the light, depending
upon the weather,
depending upon my emotion
when I look at it, right?
In other words, reality
is much more complicated.
And so that when we look at
the Rouen Cathedral paintings,
we're aware of paint.
We're aware not just of
the fact that a cathedral
is being represented.
We're aware of the
process whereby
Monet went through the terrific
labor of capturing the image.
And you can see there's a lot
of examples even on painting
of the thickness of the paint.
When you look at
Monet's paintings,
very often the paint is so
thick that if you see in reality
you want to reach
out and touch it.
So you're aware of the
materials that go in-- again,
another kind of
self-consciousness
or self-reflexiveness.
Well, Hitchcock belongs in
that tradition, I think.
And a great many of his mature
films have this double plot.
Right?
The second plot is
what we might call
the drama of the watching,
the drama of watching.
And Rear Window was a
particularly austere ingredient
instance of this topic.
Well, let me start over
again with Shadow of a Doubt,
set the context.
It's World War II was going on.
I already mentioned that
Hitchcock had already
felt ambivalent
about leaving England
at the end of the 1930s.
And now, by 1943, this anxiety--
because the war was on,
England was being attacked.
Hitchcock felt
ambivalence about that.
His mother was tremendously ill,
he kept receiving information.
And she couldn't
get back to England
because the war was going on.
You couldn't travel there.
And it was said that
he was afflicted
by a kind of a really
deep guilt and unhappiness
during the filming
of Shadow of a Doubt.
And during the filming of Shadow
of a Doubt, his mother died.
Now there are some
film critics who
say, Oh well, the
port-- well there's
one critic who writes that
the portrait of the mother
in Shadow of a
Doubt is Hitchcock's
last benign portrait
of a mother.
But if this is a
benign portrait,
I'm very nervous about
what is a mean portrait.
And it's a very bad mistake.
I mean, it can't
be that Hitchcock
was trying to memorialize his
mother in the primary character
in this film.
Because as you'll see,
she's a magnificent airhead.
The only dumber woman
in film that I know
is Annabelle Lee
in The General, who
sweeps out the
engine while they're
trying to escape their enemies.
And as you'll see,
she's a figure--
she's a benign
figure in the sense
that she has not a
mean bone in her body.
But she's really a dullard.
She's really silly.
And she silly in ways
the film is aware of.
But we'll come back to that.
So there are elements in
the film of autobiography,
but there are skewed
by Hitchcock's
own sour, cynical,
disturbed nature.
And this portrait of
a family is very far
from being a
celebratory portrait,
as will say in a moment.
So Hitchcock's in exile.
He's feeling a bit sour,
he's feeling alienated.
So he makes a film in which--
really his first film, or one
of his first films-- in
which an American family is
at the very center
of the story, right?
But he treats this family with
an odd kind of comic irony
or distance that careful
viewers immediately see
and lazy viewers might not see.
But the careful
viewers definitely see.
And one way to pick
up on how subversive
his portrait of
the family is, is
to compare him to his great
contemporary Frank Capra.
We've seen a Capra film already,
of course, that standard
and establishing
screwball comedy.
But the more characteristic
Capra films--
all of these kinds of
film were also coming out
at the same time-- are
even more fundamentally
celebrations of American life.
And maybe the quintessential
instances of this as a film,
that anyone who lives
in the United States
for a few months
around Christmas time
becomes sick of,
what's the film?
Starring Jimmy
Stewart, who was also
the star of one of tonight's
Hitchcock film, Rear Window.
What's the film?
It's a Wonderful Life, yes.
And in fact the title tells--
Capra-- although there is
a dark side to Capra, too.
But Capra's the great American
sentimental and optimist.
He celebrates small town
virtues, celebrates--
and the villains
in Capra's films
are Big Business
and people who are
hostile to the values
of small town America.
Hitchcock-- and one way of
understanding what Hitchcock
is doing in Shadow--
so I feel like it's
A Wonderful Life-- also,
incidentally, these films
often star Jimmy
Stewart-- James Stewart.
But when Hitchcock
uses James Stewart,
this upstanding, perfect example
of middle American decency
and American honesty is
turned into a much more
fearful, damaged, impotent
sometimes sexually
perverted or implicitly
sexually damaged adult.
And it was Hitchcock's version
of Jimmy-- the Jimmy Stewart
that Hitchcock draws out is a
much more disturbed and damaged
character.
And part of what makes Stewart's
performances in Hitchcock's
films so powerful--
there's some people
say Hitchcock and
Stewart's collaboration
was one of the
great collaborations
between a director and an
actor in the history of movies.
And you could see one great
example of it in Rear Window.
But the primary
thing to recognize
is that what Hitchcock is
doing something so subversive,
because Jimmy
Stewart was already
a kind of American icon.
He stood when he-- except
in Hitchcock's films--
he stood for a form of
American decency and openness
and honesty and sincerity,
goodness and even heroism.
Which Hitchcock undermines in
all kinds of-- I don't mean
that he makes Jimmy Stewart
an evil character, he doesn't!
And he him his outwardly
heroic lineaments.
But then we discover that there
are things wrong with him,
as you'll see in Rear Window.
And he does this
again in Vertigo,
an even more dramatic example
of Jimmy Stewart playing
an impaired or a
damaged character.
In Rear Window,
Jimmy Stewart has
one leg that's broken, right?
In a cast for all the film.
As you'll see.
At the very end of the film--
one of the outcomes of the film
is what-- in the denouement--
we see Jimmy Stewart
after the action has occurred
and now he has two broken legs.
So he's back where he
was in the beginning.
He's even more
damaged, and impaired,
and immobilized
than he was before!
And we'll come back to
this, because there's
something very disturbing about
this ending in a certain way.
Even though it purports to
be a kind of survival tale
and in that sense, a
kind of happy ending.
But the important
point for the moment
is that Hitchcock was certainly
fully aware of the fact
that what he was
doing was juxtaposing
his much more sour,
unsentimental, even
cynical vision of American
life against Capra's more
sentimental one, right?
So it's as if he's
against Capra.
Or he's against Capricorn.
The corniness.
Get the pun?
I'm stealing it,
I'm stealing it.
But the corniness,
the sentimentality
of a characteristic Capra film.
And the characteristic
attitude in the Capra film
towards small town
American life.
And one of the ways
to recognize this
is to recognize a kind
of recurring trope of his
that I've mentioned before.
Let's show it, Kristen.
So here is the opening
Shadow of a Doubt.
I'm giving you a chance
to watch it and then
savor it the second
time when you
see it again, in 20
minutes, half an hour or so.
And it dramatizes a
scene, a version of which
occurs in many Hitchcock films.
Watch what happens.
In which the effect
of the opening
is in some sense to
implicate the viewer
right at the beginning
in an act of voyeurism.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: See?
A benign scene.
A benign cityscape.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: We go
up to the window.
In Psycho, it's
even more dramatic.
The film actually crawls
under a window shade
that's almost all the way down.
But you see what the camera did?
[KNOCK ON THE DOOR]
CHARLIE: Come in.
PROFESSOR: OK, stop.
When we first see Young
Charlie in the film many,
many scenes later,
what we've just
looked at will be
replicated, shot by shot.
It's an example of what
I call rhyming scenes.
And I'll come back
to that in a moment.
So behind any door or
window is potential evil.
And the way that we
go out in the street,
that then the camera
looks up at a window,
then it goes implicitly
through the window.
And as I say, in
some Hitchcock films,
the slithering
through the window
is actually even more explicit.
And you actually feel that
the camera has slid in,
as if it's a kind of unwelcome
and unobserved witness
to the event.
And the implication is that
you are watching something
that you shouldn't be
watching, or that you
have access to worlds that
normally you would never
have access to.
So behind any door window
in Hitchcock's world
can be evil, danger, fright.
An American town,
an American family.
I've already mentioned that
one of the things that's
going on in this film is a
portrait of an American family
that has a kind of ironic
undercutting built into it.
We can feel almost
from the very beginning
when we first go to Santa Rosa.
Our first shots of
Santa Rosa-- which
will occur shortly after
the scene you've just seen.
You'll see, there will be a more
elaborated scene in which we
learn a little bit more
about Uncle Charlie,
and then we shift to Santa Rosa.
And the very opening
scene in Santa Rosa
shows a sort of fat, jolly
policeman in bright sunlight
directing traffic.
As if nothing could be
more wonderful than the job
of directing traffic in
a small American town
in sunny California.
What could be more noble?
But there's something
excessive about it.
I mean, you almost feel,
even before you fully
realize that what the
film is going to be doing,
you sort of feel that
this is too much.
And this is characteristic
of Hitchcock as well.
Almost as if there's
an excess of brightness
and an excessive jolliness.
As if it's more than we
could possibly believe.
And then, as the family's
nature begins to unfold to us,
what we begin to see is
these children are horrible,
insipid children.
They're hardly admirable.
The daughter's a
nasty little bitch
who is more interested
in reading her books
that in speaking
civilly to her parents.
Not long Charlie, but
Charlie's younger sister.
There are three
children the family.
Charlie's the oldest, right?
And then, she has a sister
and a younger brother.
And the younger
brother and the sister
are insipid, nasty
little children.
The boy when we see
him is constantly
saying, what-- when he
first sees Uncle Charlie,
he says, "What have you got?
What present have
you gotten for me?"
And if we don't think that the
children are very attractive,
wait till we look more closely
at the fact the parents.
I've already
mentioned the father,
who spends most of
his most of his time
with Hume Cronyn trying to talk
about ridiculous diversions
in murder mysteries.
Meanwhile, his family
is in danger around him
and he doesn't have
any sense of it.
But the wife, as
I've mentioned also,
comes across as one of
the supreme airheads
in American movies.
There's a certain moment
when Uncle Charlie is
under suspicion,
so some FBI agents
come to town in disguise.
And they suspect him but
they don't have evidence yet.
So they claim they're
from a magazine,
and they come into the
family and they say,
"What we want to
do is we want to do
a story about a typical
American family."
And the mother of the
family is very proud.
"Oh, isn't it nice to be a
typical representative American
family?"
Well, who would want
to be the mean, right?
We're the mean, we're
the norm, right?
We are the typical--
but she loves this idea.
And then, not only
does she love the idea,
she's really rather
a silly person.
So at one point
when they're getting
ready to sort of-- I don't
know whether they're getting
ready to do still
photography in the house--
she insists on
completing her cooking
because she wants to finish
the pie before the photographer
gets there.
As if completing her
cooking has something
to do with what the
photographer would find.
And you find repeatedly that
she's kind of a little askew.
She certainly has no
possible intimation
that her brother is a
murderer and in fact
a cynical nihilist that has no
respect for anything in life.
And she never learns
any better, and that's
part of what makes the
film so disturbing.
So what happens in the course
of the film essentially
is that this American
family is systematically
shown to be sort of
silly and foolish,
banal in its ordinariness.
Hardly something that
we might fully-- I
don't mean to say that we come
away in horror thinking, Oh!
How disgusting this family is!
Just that we think how ordinary,
banal, silly, foolish it is.
One of the ways
I've talked already
about the way in which Hitchcock
is obsessed by doublings.
And by the idea
of a self divided.
And one of his richest
treatments of that theme
is in the treatment of Uncle
Charlie and Young Charlie.
And you'll see how explicit
the film is about that.
One of the ways it's
explicit about it
is that Hitchcock uses
particular visual strategies
to reinforce the connection.
And I've already mentioned the
rhyming scene in that opening
scene.
Watch it, because
it's quite exciting.
Later, in our first
introduction to Young Charlie,
the camera behaves
identically to the way
it behaved when we
saw Uncle Charlie.
And so even before Uncle
Charlie has entered the story,
even before we're
fully aware of what
the relationship between Uncle
Charlie and Young Charlie is,
the camera has told us
that they are linked.
And we can say then
that in the doubling
Young Charlie represents
a kind of innocence
and part of her night--
one way to understand
the film is to see it
as a Bildungsroman,
as a growing up, as an
initiation story in which Young
Charlie learns
something about the evil
and difficulty of the world.
She has a naive and
simplified view of the world,
and before she's
done, she comes face
to face, not just with murder,
but with the possibility
of murder.
And in fact, Uncle Charlie
actually tries to murder her,
because he realizes she
knows the truth about him.
So she's in danger
for part of the film,
and knows she's in danger.
And part of the issue is that
she can't really talk about it.
Why not?
Well, it's her uncle!
Have you ever heard
this kind of thing?
There are actually critics who
say that although that it's
never made explicit in the
film, that one of the ways
to understand the film, and
at least in the subtextual way
is to think about the relation
between Uncle Charlie and Young
Charlie as that between the
sort of perverted uncle man who
manhandles his young niece
when his family isn't watching,
right?
And there actually
is in the film what
is a scene sometimes called a
betrothal scene in which we see
Young Charlie come
down a staircase,
like a traditional
bride down a staircase,
and Uncle Charlie
gives her a ring.
So that's the film does insinu--
and that's really perverted.
The film doesn't actually say
anything sexual is going on
between uncle and niece.
That's not-- but there
are these suggestions
of illicit or
disturbing connections
that are part of the subtext
with which we experience
the film and with
which we recognize
the tangled, disturbing quality
of the connection between Young
Charlie and her uncle.
So the naivete on
Young Charlie's part
is her failure to
understand or to even to
be able to imagine the
extent of evil and duplicity
in the world.
And we could say
that what happens
as she comes to recognize
what Uncle Charlie really is,
and what Uncle Charlie
really stands for,
she is educated into
the ways of the world.
But it is in many ways a very
terrible and very serious
initiation.
And one of the climactic
instances of this
occurs toward the
end of the film
when Young Charlie and
her uncle meet together
in a bar called the-- think it's
called the Till Two because it
closes at 2:00,
which is very late.
In the universe of
the film, 2:00 AM
is very late in Santa
Rosa, California.
They meet in this
place, and this
is where Uncle
Charlie realizes he
can no longer hide the truth.
And he talks openly
to Young Charlie,
and he says at one point this.
"We're old friends, Charlie.
More than that,
we're like twins.
You said so yourself.
You think you're the
clever little girl who
knows something.
There's so much you
don't know, so much.
You're just an ordinary
little girl living
in an ordinary little town--"
You hear the contempt
for ordinary there?
Hitchcock shares some of
this, even though his villain
is saying it, right?
"You go through your
ordinary little day at night
and you sleep your untroubled,
ordinary little sleep, filled
with peaceful, stupid dreams.
You live in a dream--"
This is a direct quotation.
"You live in a dream.
You're a sleepwalker.
Blind.
How do you know what
the world is like?
Do you know the
world is a foul sty?
Do know that if you rip
the fronts off houses
you'd find swine?
The world's a hell.
What does it matter
what happens in it?"
Now what an extreme
nihilistic statement.
That's what Uncle
Charlie stands for.
That's the full
ugliness and disturbance
that Young Charlie--
and, of course,
a murder is speaking to her.
This is also implicitly
a confession to her.
"Yes, I have killed people."
So it's a tremendously
disturbing moment in the film,
and it represents
in a certain way
Young Charlie's coming of age.
But the irony, or one
tremendous irony of this tale,
of this story, is that when
we get to the end of the film,
there is a profound
kind of ambiguity.
Yes, the evil has been purged.
I won't go into the
details of the plot
so as not to spoil your
experience of the film,
but Uncle Charlie is eliminated
from the scene in a--
and Young Charlie survives.
It's a kind of reassuring
or happy ending.
But what undercuts it?
As all, remember all,
of Hitchcock's endings
are undercut, they're
never really happy.
They're never really reassuring.
They go through the motions.
They're conventionally
reassuring, but they're not.
The moral ambiguity on
which this film ends
is maybe it's most
disturbing aspect.
Because what it says--
because Young Charlie never
tells her mother,
never tells her father,
never reveals to the
community that Uncle Charlie
was this evil figure, was
the Merry Widow murder.
Why not?
Well, maybe she
sparing her mother.
Uncle Charlie's no longer
there, what's the difference?
There's no discussion of this.
But what does it mean?
It means that when
the film is over,
the idea that evil
might lurk at the heart
of the American family
remains a reality
that no one has acknowledged.
In other words, it's as if
the implications of the story
are denied bye
Charlie's silence.
And we're left in the
situation at the end
of the film in which
the implications
or meaning of Uncle Charlie's
life has been suppressed.
And therefore, the significance
of his pervasive nihilism
and of what it means that
such nihilism could exist
at the heart of a
typical American family
is never acknowledged or known
by anyone inside the film.
Even though it's a
disturbing knowledge
that we take away from the film.
So to conclude on this
film, one of the things
to think about as
you're watching the film
is how remarkably Hitchcock
is able to give us
what might be thought
in many ways to be,
and what is in many ways,
a light entertainment.
A humorous and very well
put together mystery story
about an American family full
of the wit and scene by scene
richness and complexity.
A film that even naive
film goers can enjoy fully.
And yet the full
implications of it,
the moral ambiguity with
which the film ends,
and the moral ambiguity
that's a really implicit all
the way through the film,
the sense of the ominous
and the sense of disturbance
remains with the viewer
after the film is over.
It's a characteristic way
for Hitchcock to end films.
Rear Window, as
I've suggested, is
an even more
rigorous exploration
of some of Hitchcock's deepest
preoccupations and obsessions.
Let me remind you
to really savor
the opening scene of the film.
It starts under the titles,
and you get the title sequence,
and onto the title-- it's
a sequence that lasts
three or almost four minutes.
And it's completely wordless.
There is no dialogue.
Watch how much what happens.
It's a complicated
moment in a certain way.
But if you are attentive to it,
you can see what's happening.
Essentially, what we see
the camera do-- first,
we see the blinds go
up on two open windows.
And then we realize that
they're open windows,
they're encasement windows
that are open unscreened.
And after the blinds--
the camera is stable,
it doesn't move-- three
separate blinds go up one time.
They reveal the other
side of an apartment
complex being seen through the
window of another apartment.
And then, what we see-- the
camera then goes on and sort
of elaborate journey.
You're caught in the
camera's gaze, as a viewer.
Once the shades go up, then
the camera begins to move.
It moves toward the window,
then it moves out the window,
and then it looks
down and it does
a kind of circuit of
the-- essentially,
it shows you what can be
seen from this window.
It does a kind of circuit
of the physical spaces that
are open it if it looked at
this world from this window.
And you see it might
make a kind of circle,
it's not a 360 degree turn
but it's more than 180.
The camera turns like this,
it pans, it turns around,
and then it comes
back into the room.
And when it comes back into the
room-- it goes out of the room
and it looks around, and then
it comes back into the room,
through the same windows,
backs up further,
and then you see
Jimmy Stewart lying
there, sweating in the heat.
The camera then looks up
a wall at a thermometer,
and you see the
thermometer is hovering
in the mid 90s someplace,
explaining why Jimmy Stewart is
sweating so much.
But then, the camera
moves outside again
and does another circle of the
space that you just looked at.
It's almost as if it wants
you to look at a second time,
to remind you of the space
of the action in the film.
And of course, we don't
fully realize it at the time,
but this is a rehearsal
for the whole movie,
because we are going to
be confined in exactly
this way for the entire film.
We're never going to
get out of this room.
Everything we see will be
seen through this window.
Then the camera come
pulls back in again,
we see Jimmy Stewart
again-- so it's
almost as if that
opening sequence does
the same thing twice.
What it mostly does, of
course, is trap the viewer
in an act of voyeurism.
It traps the viewer completely
in an act of spying.
And then, almost the very first
words of the film, the camera
pulls back, it
looks at a few items
to tell us a little
more about the fact
that Jimmy Stewart
is a photographer who
works for a magazine,
who was injured taking
one of his action photos.
He can't wait to till
he's out of his cast,
but he has another week to
go and he's going stir crazy.
And then he has a
conversation on the telephone
with his editor.
And at the same time engages
in various acts of voyeurism,
including especially
a young woman
who is scantily clad across
the courtyard in her room
wearing shorts and a
very revealing brassiere
doing sort of exercises
and so forth while she's
eating her breakfast.
And you see the Jimmy Stewart
character voyeuristically
savoring her as he's
talking to his friend.
And then he hangs up the phone,
a knock comes on the door,
a woman enters.
It's his cleaning lady
played by the great actress--
what's her name?--
Thelma Ritter.
And Thelma's almost
first words are,
"We've become a nation
of peeping Toms."
And I mention this
just to show you
how aware the film is,
how much the film wants
us to be aware of the
fact, that voyeurism is one
of its deep subjects, right?
Why do we have this desire
to watch the illicit?
What is it about us
that wants to make
us sort of look through key
holes and peep at people
and watch the intimate
lives of people?
So they saw the opening
scene is a scene that
dramatizes the confinement
and the voyeurism that
are at the very heart of
what the movie is about.
We can say that the whole essay,
the whole film in some sense,
is a kind of essay on seeing.
And in that three or
four minute sequence
in the beginning
without dialogue,
the camera is the star,
in a certain sense.
We become aware of the
camera, as Hitchcock
wants us to be, in
a way we would never
be in another kind of film.
There are other forms
of elegance in the film.
And I hope you'll watch
the way the camera behaves,
because it's a marvel of
complexity and intelligence.
But there's another
way in which there's
an elegance of
structure in the film.
As the camera in
the very beginning
makes its tour of
the building, what
begins to emerge in a very
elementary way at first,
and then as the film precedes
becomes more fleshed out,
is that there are three or
four basic stories about people
who live in the apartments that
Jimmy Stewart is looking into.
And each of them tells a
separate kind of story.
There's a Miss
Lonely Heart story
about a woman who was
pining for a boyfriend
and who feels very
lonely and maybe toying
with the idea of suicide.
Then there's a story
about a composer who's
having trouble with his work.
They're a series of sort of
subplots, mostly trivial ones.
Except for the primary one--
what's the primary one?
A murder may have been committed
in one of the apartments
to Jimmy Stewart has
been prying into.
And he begins to
investigate the murder
and that puts him
in danger himself.
And the people involved with
him, including his girlfriend
Grace Kelly, get
involved in the danger
as well because he's a immobile.
And Grace has to be the one
who walks across the way,
and does--
So the elegance of the
structure of the film
has partly to do with the way
in which these subplots work
themselves out.
And at the end of the film,
each of these little subplots
that we'd seen being played out
in these different apartments--
only watching them through the
windows of the apartments--
each of them is
resolved in some way.
And I want to suggest that
their resolution, while from one
angle is very satisfying--
there's a kind of elegance
of structure.
We're very satisfied by
this sense of completion.
But at the same time,
I think the very fact
that these stories
are all tied up
in such neat knots makes us
feel that there's something
a little too neat, a little
too perfect about it.
In other words,
the very perfection
with which these subplots
are tied up at the end
suggests a kind of
excess that Hitchcock
wants us to be suspicious of.
As if of this is
just too perfect.
And of course,
there are other ways
in which the ending of this
film is deeply ambiguous.
And I'll come back
to that in a moment.
I also ought to
mention the way it
which, in a quiet,
subtle way, this film is
an exploration of both
class and gender issues.
Because there's a kind of
little sort of contest going on.
Grace Kelly, who's this
elegant upper class
woman who gets her clothes at
the fanciest fashion stores
and has food catered from
the fanciest restaurants
in the city and who reads
magazines like Vogue
and so forth-- she stands
for sort of moneyed elegance.
And there's a kind of
tension between them.
She wants to marry Jimmy Stewart
and Jimmy Stewart's resisting.
One reason is that he doesn't
belonged to her class.
He's more of a working
class type, right?
He's a down to
earth sort of guy,
and he's worried about that.
And he's also nervous because
like many American males,
especially in the movies, he's
nervous about being entrapped
by marriage, as if he
isn't already entrapped
in all kinds of ways.
And in an odd kind
of way, we could
say that the Thorwald
marriage-- that's
the name of the
murderer and the wife
he supposedly murders and
chops up, at least that's
what Jimmy Stewart
comes to suspect.
We could say that
the Thorwald marriage
is a kind of double
of the marriage
that the Jimmy Stewart
character fears he will have.
That his resistance
to Grace Kelly
is partly a class resistance.
He feels uneasy around
this aristocratic woman
because her tastes seemed
to him banal and trivial.
In any case, they seem to him to
involve values and commitments
that are at odds
with a sort of rough
and tumble life of a
traveling photographer who
goes to war zones and
other dangerous places.
But that's his image of himself.
So his resistance to
her is partly a desire
to maintain his freedom, right?
And it's partly a class issue.
So that both issues of class
and gender are involved.
The gender issue has to do with
how men and women, especially
in the stereotyped way
of the '50s and '60s,
regarded the
question of marriage.
And there are other
marriages or relationships
that are alluded to
in the film, and we
can say that those marriages
and relationships also
double the relationship
between Stewart and Kelly.
So there's a kind of low
level, not exactly hostility,
but a low level badinage and
argument going on between Kelly
and Stuart all the
way through the film.
Which is in some sense resolved,
but not fully resolved.
Or resolved in a typically
unsatisfying Hitchcockian way
at the end of the film.
So the very ending of the film.
There is the tradition-- the
murderer is caught, is exposed.
The danger to which the Jimmy
Stewart character was exposed
is purged by the end.
Again I won't go into details
if you've not seen the film,
but I need to say this much in
order to explain the ending.
And at the end of
the film, as I said,
there's a moment where we see
him-- the murder finds out
that he's watching him.
And after a while, he comes
to Jimmy Stewart's apartment
apparently to try to murder him.
Because he thinks
he's going to reveal
that he's a murderer himself.
And it's a terrifying scene.
The great climax of
the scene-- Stewart--
his physical
limitations some critics
have seen as a symbolic
embodiment of what might
be seen as a form of impotence.
Both a sexual impotence and sort
of broader kind of impotence,
an incompetence because he's
crippled, he can't fight,
he can't defend himself.
He can't behave like
a traditional man
in a traditional movie.
And again, remember, this is
characteristic of Hitchcock.
His men are almost
always like this.
It's amazing, in fact, how weak,
vulnerable, damaged, fearful,
frightened his protagonists are.
So there's this climactic
moment at the end where
Thorwald, the murderer, is
trying to kill Jimmy Stewart,
and he pushes him.
And Jimmy Stewart is holding on.
He's on the second story window.
He's holding on like
this, looking up.
The camera's
looking down at him.
You see the fear and
horror in his face.
He lets go.
There's a critic,
a brilliant critic,
a French critic, who talks
about the idea of letting go,
of losing your grip as central
action in Hitchcock's films.
You lose your gripping.
You fall into a void.
And that moment that is,
as I said this afternoon,
could be said to be an iconic
moment in Hitchcock's movie.
So when Jimmy Stewart
actually lets go and falls.
You see his face as if
he's falling to his--
you think he might be
falling to his death.
But of course, he's not.
He just breaks his other leg.
And at the end of the film
then we have a final scene.
And this is where the
ambiguity comes in.
We see him with both legs, now.
He's back where he was.
But the Grace Kelly character
is sitting happily in the room.
She pretends that she's
reading material that
would please Jimmy Stewart.
But in fact, if
you look closely,
she has a copy of Vogue
hidden inside the material
that she's reading.
And there's a very deep
sense that in this gender
conflict between Grace Kelly--
and also we discover at the end
but they're now engaged.
So Jimmy Stewart has become
engaged to this woman, right?
So it's almost as if he's
sort of lost the battle.
Or at least he's
agreed to marry.
But what we feel that the end
is that his agreement to marry
her is still full of
the same ambiguities
that were present before.
And many people watching
the film have said,
you know the Grace
Kelly character is
very beautiful and very elegant,
but she's not a very attractive
person morally.
She tries to manipulate the
Jimmy Stewart character.
She doesn't seem fully
to appreciate him.
She doesn't see
why he wants to run
around the world in
corduroys and sneakers
instead of living the high
life in New York and go
and going to Le
Cirque for dinner.
She can't really
understand that.
So the conflict between them is
a kind of lifestyle conflict.
At the end of the film,
none of those things
have been resolved.
And there's the sense that
he's more entrapped than ever
at the end of the movie.
Now, I don't want to
make too much of this.
This is a light
entertainment at one level.
But these subjects that
I've been talking about,
the sense of loosing your
grip, of being caught
in a confined space and being
terrified by forces far larger
than you, that you're too
weak or damage to resist.
Those moments of
horror and terror
are dramatized with
profound authority
in this remarkable film.
So what Hitchcock repeatedly
does, and especially
in these two films,
and if you can see them
in a conversation
with each other
you'll understand more
fully, the fascination
of Hitchcock's career and
the fascination of his work.
Because he keeps returning with
these remarkable variations
again and again to the same set
of problems and of subjects.
So there's even more
ambiguity and uncertainty
at the end of Rear Window
than there was when it began.
And one final point
and then I'll stop.
One of the things that we
notice in the course of the film
is there's one moment in the
movie where the Jimmy Stewart
character responds to Grace
Kelly with a kind of excitement
and allure.
It's almost the moment
where you see suddenly
really desires her, really
sees her as a possible partner.
And it's the moment
in which she has
entered the voyeuristic drama.
It's the moment in
which he's watching her
through his lens when
she's gone across
to try to do some detective work
in the murderer's apartment.
And there's a kind of
excitement and adventure
that goes on there.
And it's actually the
moment when they bond.
When they realize-- and there
is some sense that they're both
engaged in a morally exciting,
in a mutually exciting
adventure.
But there's also the sense,
very disturbing in a way when
you reflect on it later, that
the moment in which Grace
Kelly became truly attractive
to the Jimmy Stewart character
was the moment in which he had
entered the voyeuristic drama.
In which Kelly was
now distant from,
which he was attracted to
her because he was seeing her
as if he were a peeping Tom.
So now this is a subtext.
I don't mean that I don't
mean that the film is
using a megaphone to remind
us of these implications.
But the number of them build
for the course of the film.
And as with Shadow of a Doubt,
what seems on the surface
to be a kind of light
diversion, once we
begin to press its
details becomes
a much more disturbing
and powerful meditation
on our human impulse
to watch what we're not
supposed to watch,
to participate
in illicit activities without
being punished for it,
especially if we,
like Jimmy Stewart,
are able to do so in the dark.
And in that sense, when we
step away from Rear Window,
one of the things
we might recognize
is that we in the audience
have been engaging
in the same activity
that Jimmy Stewart is
engaging in the movie.
That we are complicit as
viewers in the immorality
and in the murderous
tendencies of these forms
of entertainment.
So it's not possible if you're
an alert and self-conscious
film goer to watch these
apparent light entertainments
without recognizing their
deeper and more disturbing
implications.
[NO SPEECH]